olá a todos pessoal de quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos já mais um
vídeo e os estragos e que faz night at
freddy's 2 nos óculos rio que o
treinamento tem nada a ver muitos
comentários e muitos de vocês pedem para
fazer a noite gol de fred e eu tenho
tentado pessoa seria ontem mesmo tentado
muito todos os dias de jogos a netflix
para tentar passar a gol também fere mas
eu não consigo é muito difícil por isso
vocês vão ter que esperar um pouco mais
para que o medo e se viu aqui no canal e
agora vou escolher uma testemunha haiti
já volto
e já que estamos só com o frete freires
dois dentro dos jogos rift está muito o
si mesmo e os primeiros a conseguir
triunfar max e fredson e não estava
sendo bem feito mas bora lá então
pessoal do cara que é ladies night
basicamente uma questão night um do rio
nem todos os animais tronics femininos
do jogo basicamente ética ética e
emendou o passe que matheus é raposas
feminino e vou ter que ter muito cuidado
pessoal o saxon apenas trecho
animatronics mas são as mais complicadas
porque a obra pronta falar nela por fmi
e como vocês viram o pessoal nem um
minuto possui um rio logo só pra vocês
verem dificuldade de jogar com óculos
quito o cross porque na verdade não é
que esta meta que é difícil é mesmo
conseguir que acertar com o rato na
masculina câmara porque e um cheiro a
cabeça como vocês podem ver o rato
também mexe então é muito mais
complicado jogar aqui
o que ela vai saltar para cima não calma
o garçom cade o encontro vai separá las
nénão elas estão destruídos apenas como
foi em nota calma calma ela vai aparecer
aqui né zé pinto amarela o que é uma
calma para superar seu único amigo tony
que está aqui que tem prêmio não é por
isso eu tenho uma grande sorte de estar
no meio desanimado jovens meninas não é
porque um homem no meio de três mulheres
já sabendo que aqui foi na meta ao
tentar marcar uma data triste que
concentrar em falar - por que esta noite
vai ser muito difícil calma calma não
leu a raposa já está lá em cima seja
tudo já estava em cima vamos saltar para
cima né
ela vai voltar para o rio
como fui rápido o rap eu acho que esse é
pintar amarela não vai faltar nem aqui
está tudo tranquilo mas josé raposo
jornal i
mais cedo ou mais tarde ela vai dizer é
que nossas calma eu fui rápido fui
rápido aí vai te embora a raposa se não
pagasse não pagasse uma pessoa a ser
vista muita opção é muita pressão muita
forte impressão aqui sair raposa saiu e
ela já havia muito tempo não faz nada
ela tá mal estar muito ela tem uma
história muito com quanto ao barulho eu
tô tranquilo tranquilo tranquilo
sai daí raposa falar só de raposa
ela não vai sair pois não calma pessoal
está muito superior
mesmo com os olhos fechados sob aquela
coisa amarelo porque aquela luz passa
membrana aqui do olho e sérios ter muito
assustador com os riffs que mais vamos
continuar eu não garanto que vou
conseguir passar esta noite pessoal mas
pelo menos até às três da manhã eu quero
tentar passar por isso por lá anda lá em
de meia noite ela já vai aparecer em
todas aqui meu calma dar que vai
conseguir passar esta noite bom
o google ou anda alguém a ventilação
calma
tranquilo tranquilo e muito
provavelmente aquela mata mata que vai
ficar aqui um bocadinho acalmar o
coração calma e não perceber porque é
que você fred ficar aqui ou lá pra mim
esses supostamente é uma ladies night tu
não és uma menina fred site ok pessoal
simular um pouco é porque estou muito
concentrado vocês já sabem como é que
funciona aqui o fanatismo fred escorou
da guiné se eu começar a ficar muito
calado é porque uma toca ok ok nao ta
soltar porque por tudo isso vai ficar
com ela mas falou da mesma e por josé
pinto amarelar parece né
ok ok é já muito importante mudar disse
para ficar com ela ainda fala mais nada
aqui as raposas amarok ela fosse morar
foi a senhora tem que aproveitar
anda a correr após a curva parece que
alguém não foram senhora caiana
aproveitar aproveitar o boom foi rápida
e econômica
eu não percebi porque é que zé pinta
pendentes na boca quando os pais não
podem ter 20 mil
anda lá lá lá anda rápido será na quinta
aposento
ela tem que ir embora calma vou ter que
esperar que ela vai embora e só aí caiu
a ficha foi né
tudo bem tudo banda larga que está com a
palhaça fiscal não é um gato ou gata ela
vai perceber quem olha vai parecer não
sabia meu pai seria o pessoal deu mesmo
que o pressentimento que ela ia aparecer
mas mesmo assim eu fui burro no fmi e
não pude vir meu tempo me concentrar e
segurar o jogo e ela jamais pareceu não
pode ser pessoal a ser isto está muito
difícil geraram aqui nesta noite meu tá
mesmo muito difícil o caso
calma calma tranquilo eu acho que você
falasse nos aparece um tac distrito não
posso tomar tanta atenção 11 palácio mas
é pintar não é hoje que mais comeram lá
alguém está a mentir em prática eu acho
que as raposas calma o gogol o alguém
mas como é possível este jogo não pode
ser não pode ser possível
não é não é possível nem ela é filha da
mãe e filha dela e ela vai pra frente eu
saí a jesus calma cá o gol o vovô vôo
estão sendo até pronta quiser raposa gil
sabe é meu
agora com sua noite por um tipo de
câmera pessoal vocês viram rafael ii
ninguém qualquer momento eu nunca sei
quando aquelas roupas e viram agora só
não fui ver a quebra ela próximo logo
mel
calma calma calma calma é um marco para
gastar aqui também acusa aquela só
embora ficar uma pagar 50 e aguenta aí
para 51 precisou sabia eu sabia vender
solo meu pressentimento está sempre
certo é que tem que ser mais rápido em
relação ao meu sentimento meu
calma calma calma é o que agora estava
errado lá cão marco zero o rappa está
falando muito jogar com a pesquisa mesmo
muito complicado então scapol 2 mil
dólares já portas prontas podem saltar
em cima
calma calma calma da actu não tá comigo
não esse é o tempo psicológico falar
mais alto não tá comendo tas muito bem
que nem esquenta e espero não está ok
pessoal não dá mesmo eu acho que nós
vamos ficar porque com isso faz night at
freddy's 2 nos óculos livre e esta noite
e fica mais difícil não só com os ricos
porque se o abanar a cabeça o rato
também mexe operar logo encontrou então
não dá pra falar será completamente
impossível e foi apenas um teste para
ver se os jogos que funcionavam bem com
este ou e funciona um pouco bem apesar
de isso não ser o meu rádio tudo mas é
isso pessoal espero que vocês tenham
gostado deixa o flick favorito fiquem
bem e até a próxima
o